Let's look at the 4th country with the greatest inequality
and poverty throughout the European Union,
only behind Romania,
Bulgaria and Greece.
For you it is 1 merit of the social prototype deployed
by the progressive government and emphasis must be placed on
of being 4th by the Cola in inequality.
In addition, Mr. Minister,
I will tell you that beyond
of the cold eh macro figures
we all know that eh,
statistics can be twisted until they run out
confessing what 1 what 1 wants,
right?
The reality experienced by Spaniards is that if in 2000
the year 2 019 only 1 3 per 100
confessed
to feel lower or poor class
in uh,
you have managed to multiply them by 6
and reaches almost 18 percent,
this is the reality of families,
that's why I tell him
that you can make up the CPI data
overestimating,
undervaluing the weight of some
of some products,
but in the end the Spaniards
when the purchase is going to be made
and as VA approaches the end of the month,
know perfectly well if they live better or if they live worse